Global warming is expected to change Earth's weather in dramatic ways.
The best computer models predict the US,...
...West Mediterranean nations and Brazil ...
...will be "hot spots" that will get extremes at their worst.
These areas will likely suffer more extended droughts,...
...heavy rainfalls and longer heat waves.
It's estimated that the expected global average temperature change...
...will range from 2.5 degrees Fahrenheit, 1.4 degrees Celsius to 10.4 degrees Fahrenheit, 5.8 degrees Celsius.
In Korea, the expected consequences of global warming will be very bad.
In particular,...
...the tropical night's phenomenon which is already very bad will get much worse...
...as the average nighttime temperature is expected to greatly increase.
When heat waves and their intensity, length, and occurrence increase; people die.
For Korea, another negative impact will be much less predictable monsoon seasons.
This will lead to more drought and at the same time more flooding, both...
...of which will hurt food self-sufficiency.
Sea level rise will cause Korea to lose land especially in the south and western areas.
One way that Korea will do its part to slow down global warming...
...will be to use more nuclear power...
....to generate electricity rather than using oil and coal which produce greenhouse gases.
Korea is also a leading producer of automobiles...
...and is rich enough in both income and technology...
...to produce and adopt hybrid and other alternative energy vehicles...
...as new technologies become available.